MALE SPEAKER: Thanks, everyone,
for coming out to the talk
"Food and Beer,"
which I hope when
you heard that title for
a talk, you were just
as excited as I was
when this was first
proposed to the Talks team.
So without any further ado,
I'm going to hand it over
to chef Daniel
Burns, brewer Jeppe
Jarnit-Bjergso, and their
co-author Joshua David Stein.
JOSHUA DAVID STEIN: Thank you.
Hi everyone.
Yeah.
It's an easy sell,
food and beer,
and we're really
happy to be here.
I think I speak for all of us.
So the idea of the
book, obviously,
and these guys can talk
about it more, is--
both these guys
have deep knowledge,
Daniel in the world
of fine dining,
having worked at some of the
best restaurants in the world,
including the Fat Duck, Noma
where he was pastry chef,
he headed research and
development for Momofuku here
in the city, St. John's.
So kind of like
the greatest hits.
And Jeppe is--
JEPPE JARNIT-BJERGSO:
Just making beer.
JOSHUA DAVID STEIN:
Just a dude making beer.
But some of the
best beer and most
highly-rated beer in the world.
So just so you guys know,
they have this restaurant out
in Greenpoint called
Torst, and then in the back
there's a part of
it called Luksus.
And that's kind of how
we set up the book,
in the sense that the
first part of the book
takes you through
the Torst experience,
and it's really centered
around flavors of beer,
and the kind of diversity
of flavor in beer,
and its assonance and
resonance within cuisine.
And then the Luksus section
in the back really walks you
through the tasting
menu, and what
that would feel like
being at Luksus,
which only has 16 seats, right?
DANIEL BURNS: 16, yeah.
JOSHUA DAVID STEIN:
So the chances
of you eating there are slim,
although everyone should try.
It's a wonderful experience.
But I kind of wanted to start
it off-- these guys speak really
passionately about where we are
in the culinary world in terms
of beer.
Maybe Jeppe, you
could start about
before you opened
Torst and Luksus,
what was the status of
beer within fine dining?
JEPPE JARNIT-BJERGSO:
I mean, I got
into craft beer or bitter
beer, whatever you call it,
about 20 years ago.
I'm actually older than I look.
[INAUDIBLE] and back
then I don't think
it even existed in fine dining.
I mean, I didn't
do that much fine
dining back then,
obviously, since I
didn't have a lot of money.
But the couple
times I did it, they
might have some
beers on the menu,
but they were all pretty
bad, or not very [INAUDIBLE].
I moved to New York
about four years ago
and started exploring
the dining scene here,
and went to some of these
restaurants that [INAUDIBLE].
But before I moved to Noma,
it was a perfect example,
going to these restaurants
that were considered some
of the best in the world,
some of the best in the city,
in the country.
And, you know, food was
awesome, wine list was awesome,
I looked at the beer
list-- that's actually
how I got to work with Noma.
I was eating there
one day, and Noma
is considered one of the best
restaurants in the world,
and I was looking at the
beer list and I was like,
what the hell is this?
It was just a bunch of
random beers they put on,
and it wasn't well thought out.
I remember that somebody
from Noma came down,
and he's one of
the most recognized
sommeliers in the world.
And he came down, and
he knew I was a beer guy
and I was a brewer and all
that, and he probably showed me
the beer list, and he was
like, so what do you think?
And I glanced at it, I
looked at him, and I said,
it looks pretty bad actually.
And he was like, what the
hell do you mean by that?
But instead of getting offended,
we started a conversation,
and I had a meeting with
him after and I told him,
I can help you
out if you wanted.
I know you're very good at wine,
doesn't mean you necessarily
good at good beer.
And, you know, he took
my advice in this,
and we redid the
whole thing, actually.
So we're down from about
50 different beers to five
that were all
brewed specifically
for Noma, that had a
story, had flavor that
actually matched what they did.
So that was a long answer
to a short question.
Fine dining and beer wasn't
a big thing some years ago.
JOSHUA DAVID STEIN:
And for you, Daniel,
when you were working
in-- I mean, I don't know.
Do you feel like working
in the kitchen, beer, is
it true that that's what
guys drink in the kitchen
but not in the dining room?
DANIEL BURNS: After shift
drinking, that's it.
Well, I've seen a
similar thing in sort
of like the last
five, six years, when
you go have these bigger
menus at [? EMP ?]
or places like that
throughout the world, that
like when they say 10
beverage pairs, 10 years ago,
for sure 10 is wine.
Now might be one or two
cocktails, one or two beers.
So the sommeliers
always think about, they
have zero budget,
access to every wine
anywhere in the
world, and they still,
when they see the
ten dishes to pair,
they're thinking
about beers now.
Which is, I mean, that
says everything basically.
JOSHUA DAVID STEIN: But when you
were starting at the Fat Duck,
for instance, beer wasn't
part of the initial scene.
DANIEL BURNS: It wasn't, no.
And it's-- as we
say with the book,
that's a big thing that
we're trying to bring
into the conversation
of fine dining and beer.
And yeah, they said
it before, wouldn't it
be great fast forward even a few
years, or five years from now,
that all the best
restaurants would
have beer as a pairing option?
JOSHUA DAVID STEIN:
Yeah, I guess
I should stop here
and just mention
that Luksus is the only
Michelin-starred restaurant
to only have a beer pairing.
So they are kind
of leading the way.
It is true that other
Michelin-starred restaurants do
have beer, but you can't-- I
don't know about you, Daniel,
Jeppe loves wine a lot.
But you can't have wine
at Luksus or Torst.
It's just not on the menu.
JEPPE JARNIT-BJERGSO:
Well, we opened the place
three years ago.
We actually had made a decision
and only got a beer license,
which you can do.
And you can do beer, and beer,
wine, and spirits, or whatever,
but we only chose to
have a beer license.
And again, it's not
that we don't like wine,
but we just wanted
to don't lose focus.
We didn't want to open
up and start with beer,
and then people are going
to come in and say hey,
can we please do some wine?
And it's easy to fall for that.
And we're like, nope, we're
only going to do beer license.
And it's actually illegal to
drink wine at our place, which
is kind of cool.
DANIEL BURNS: It makes
it hard to drink.
JOSHUA DAVID STEIN: I think
there's an interesting dynamic,
in the sense that fine
dining is traditionally
a very elite-- honestly,
an elitist thing
to do, to have that disposable
income, to live in that world.
And beer, on the other hand,
is a very democratic drink,
in the sense that everyone
here, if you wanted,
could go home and make beer.
I don't know if it
would be very good,
but it could be very good.
But you'd be hard-pressed to go
home and make a bottle of wine
from the grape to the bottle.
And I think that's one
of the dynamics that's
so interesting at
Torst and Luksus,
that just because something's
democratic and accessible,
doesn't mean it's
not high quality.
JEPPE JARNIT-BJERGSO:
No, but it's
also one of the-- I've
actually answered that question
about, lately, why
hasn't beer done a bigger
impact on fine dining?
And I actually think
it has something
to do with exactly
what you're saying.
Beer is by history
or by tradition
or whatever considered
to be a poor man's drink.
It's extremely cheap, or
used to be very cheap.
I don't know how much
a Budweiser is. $0.50.
JOSHUA DAVID STEIN:
You mean America.
JEPPE JARNIT-BJERGSO: Yeah,
it's cheap all over the world.
JOSHUA DAVID STEIN: No, no, they
changed their name to America.
And America is cheap.
JEPPE JARNIT-BJERGSO: No, but it
is considered a cheap product.
Until five, ten years ago,
most people in the world
considered it a
very cheap product.
It was something that you had to
get drunk, pretty much, quench
your thirst.
That is definitely changing.
But it's a problem in the
fine dining restaurant world,
because it's very
hard to mark up.
The sommeliers can buy wine and
they can mark it up five times,
which they actually
do, and everybody
had to pay the
price for that wine,
because they know the wine
is supposed to be costly.
But if you take a beer and
then you mark it up five times,
you're like, why the hell do I
have to pay $15 for an America
all of a sudden, when I
only pay $2 in a store?
And that's definitely
one of the reasons
why it has been going slow
in the fine dining world.
JOSHUA DAVID STEIN: I think
another aspect, although we
talk a little bit
about it in the book,
is that after
Prohibition in America,
the type of beer that we had,
the large industrial producers
of beer weren't making beers
that had so much flavor.
And that's one of the things
that we try to do in the book,
is show the diversity
of flavor you can have.
You can have tart, fruity.
As a chef, Daniel, being able to
bounce off all those flavors--
DANIEL BURNS: Yeah, that's
actually the coolest part.
We talked a lot about wine
has all these tradition
and [INAUDIBLE] based
flavors associated with just
where the grapes grow.
You can only make certain
flavors out of the wine there.
Beer is the exact opposite.
You can take products for the
beer from all over the world,
and then add in any
flavors you want also.
So the words we've said a lot
is the spectrum of flavor,
that accessible in
terms of the beer world.
After the dish is made, it
can be much bigger than that
with wine or spirits.
So that's the exciting part.
And there's so many ways
you can go with the pairing
once it's done.
You can go very comparative
flavors with the dish,
or contrasting, or I
think the cooler one
we talked about too is that the
lesser elements in the dish,
like coriander, you can
have a beer that pairs very
well with coriander,
even though it's not
a main component in
the dish, for example.
So then the guests'
experiences-- the beer works,
but you're not actually
quite sure why it's working.
JOSHUA DAVID STEIN: Yeah, that's
what the experience of being,
especially when
you go to Luksus,
there's a beer-- is
it beer companion?
Beer host?
Somebody tells you about
all these bottles of beer
that you're drinking.
And there's amazing
stories behind every one,
that you're like that
story, those stories,
although it also exists
in wine, but these stories
are always so interesting
to me, that you have
this bottle with this history.
Usually some weirdo somewhere
doing something strange
and adding whatever they want.
This weirdo.
Jeppe, Daniel alluded
to it, that there's
kind of two different ways you
can get flavors in beer which
aren't available in wine.
You can either have
some flavors coming
from the yeast or
the hops or the malt,
or you can just say fuck it
and add what you want inside.
Like talk maybe a little
bit about Biscotti Break
as an example of that.
JEPPE JARNIT-BJERGSO:
It's a general thing
about beer-making.
We like to say there's
no laws in beer-making.
There's a lot of
laws in wine-making.
You can't do this,
you can't do that.
If you add an olive
to a wine, people
would have a hard time
taking that seriously.
I've added olive to a
beer and people love it.
Makes it a little easier.
Biscotti Break is
a perfect example.
It's a stout that I made a
couple years ago with-- we
tried to imitate a biscotti.
So we added coffee,
almond, and vanilla.
And it's something you can get
so many flavors out of that.
And now we even did a
Doughnut Break, where
we added a bunch of doughnuts.
I wanted to make it taste
like a liquid doughnut.
So we do this beer
called Doughnut Break,
and every time we make
it, we buy 1,000 doughnuts
from a small local doughnut
maker in South Carolina
and add it.
And it's fun.
It's important to state
that we do all this
to make delicious beer.
It's not just to
do something crazy.
I don't add olives just to
say hey, I added olives.
It tastes like crap,
but it was fun to do,
and people are going
to talk about it.
We do it to bring something
out, a flavor out,
that I either
haven't had before,
or a flavor I'm trying to
find from doing all this.
But it is cool that
we can do that.
Daniel, I was eating at
Luksus a couple of years ago,
and we had a dessert with
[? liquids ?] [? and beets ?]
that I loved, and I talked
with Daniel about it after.
We talked about,
wouldn't it be cool
if I made a beer with
[? liquids and beets ?]
for the appetizer, so you start
with a beer with this flavor
profile, where you have a
certain kind of the same flavor
profiles.
And he was like,
yeah, let's do it.
And it's cool that
we can do that.
I don't see how you would be
able to do that with wine.
JOSHUA DAVID STEIN:
I mean, that's
the thing about making beer
as well, it's so reactive.
There's actually a beer
coming out around the book.
Is it already out?
JEPPE JARNIT-BJERGSO: Not yet.
JOSHUA DAVID STEIN: There's a
beer that will be coming out
in celebration of the
release of the book called
"Fruit and Beer," and the
beer is called the Book Beer.
So it's all very
solipsistic, I guess.
And we went down to Charleston,
where Jeppe works with this guy
at Westbrook, and we made the
beer in-- how long did it take,
from--
JEPPE JARNIT-BJERGSO: Six hours.
JOSHUA DAVID STEIN:
Yeah, six hours.
So it's something
you can do quickly,
which gives you the
ability to kind of be
reactive and interactive
with Daniel's cuisine.
JEPPE JARNIT-BJERGSO:
Yeah, it takes so long,
you have to ferment it also.
That takes a couple
of weeks, at least.
But yeah, the actual beer-making
only takes a couple of hours.
JOSHUA DAVID STEIN: I
don't know if I ever really
asked you guys, how
does that actually
work, going through the
menu of Luksus pairing?
And how do you
guys work together?
DANIEL BURNS: The dish gets
decided, or close to decided.
And we need to taste
the dish, and that's
the time when we can try out
four or five different beers
and see which one works best.
And as you say, we can go
very widely varied in styles,
and see how they interact
with [INAUDIBLE].
JOSHUA DAVID STEIN: There's
always a clear winner
as to which one will work best.
DANIEL BURNS: But
then you also have
to think about the progression
of beers throughout the menu.
So you can't have
sour, sour, sour.
JOSHUA DAVID STEIN:
How many courses is--
DANIEL BURNS: There's
about 12, 12 servings.
So we do-- there's right now
between six or eight snacks,
and then you have
one beer with that.
And then the main dishes,
four main dishes and a palate
cleanser, so one beer with
each of the main dishes.
So five beers paired.
JOSHUA DAVID STEIN:
And I wanted to ask,
how does paired with beer,
how has that changed?
I mean, you had such a
crazy evolution as a chef.
So Daniel obviously
worked at restaurants.
He started out as
a mathematician,
then worked making soup, then
worked in high-end kitchens
on the savory side,
then went to Noma,
moved over to pastry, right?
I'm probably
skipping one or two.
Went to Fat Duck moved
to pastry, went to Noma,
became a pastry chef.
And then went to Momofuku,
and when you're not
cooking for people at
Momofuku, he stayed in a room
and came up with ideas that
drove the enterprise forward.
But you weren't plating food.
You were in that pure research.
DANIEL BURNS: That was research
and development was my title,
and in charge of making
new dishes and all
of these longer-term
fermentation projects.
Like they have the [? hoisin ?]
and stuff available now,
which is really crazy
to see that it's finally
available for purchase, when
we started working on it
five, six years ago.
JOSHUA DAVID STEIN:
So how has now
cooking, right now, creating
menus and using flavors,
knowing that you're going to be
pairing it with beer changed?
Or has it changed the way
you think about flavor,
for instance?
DANIEL BURNS: It
hasn't, actually.
I get inspired most by,
first of all, the seasons.
And then also by
travel, go to new places
and taste new-- I know
you do as well, Jeppe.
When you travel somewhere
new, you're like, holy shit,
I've never tried this
type of citrus fruit.
And even just eating the-- very
much eating the local cuisine
wherever you go, it can be
the truest form of food.
JOSHUA DAVID STEIN: What's
a good recent example?
DANIEL BURNS: I was
in Nashville recently,
and then to see the homestyle
cooking, the hot chicken
and whatever else goes
along with that, that can
be just super-honest cooking.
But most of all the
seasons, and then it's
a matter of managing it.
Now we're in the
third year, we can
start to sort of predict ahead,
OK, radishes are coming soon.
So you have to stay on top of
what's coming next in order
to change the menu
as often as we do,
because we try to change it
every four or five weeks,
that all the dishes change.
It takes a lot of foreplanning.
JOSHUA DAVID STEIN:
So yeah, that question
is a little bit about how you've
been evolving, and innovation.
And I wonder for both of you,
if you can answer, how do you
approach innovation within
Evil Twin and Torst and Luksus
in the kitchen?
And how far do you push it?
So have you failed
doing it ever?
JEPPE JARNIT-BJERGSO: It's some
very simple things, which are
[INAUDIBLE].
Evil Twin is the brewery,
and when I make beer
I don't think about
the restaurant,
because we talked about that.
We talk about it in
the book, and we've
talked about that lot.
It's important for us
to say that it's not
like we worked together creating
a beer that matches the food,
or the food matches
the beer, or whatever.
I make my beer,
Daniel makes the food.
Sometimes we use
Evil Twin, sometimes
we use something else.
I mean, it's like a sommelier.
He tastes the food, he
finds the wine that pairs,
and he puts them together.
So to talk about Evil
Twin and evolution,
you know, that's something
I think a lot about.
And I travel more
than normal people.
I think I've brewed in more
than 20 different countries
the last four years.
I'm probably the brewer that
has brewed in the most different
countries ever.
And it's something I do to
learn not just about flavors
and ingredients, but
also to learn and stay
on top of the beer evolution
all over the world.
When I started professionally
coming into craft beer
about 12 years
ago, yeah, I wanted
to make a business out of it.
And I wanted to create beer,
and I had a popular beer stall,
and I have a
distribution company,
and we have the bar, the
restaurant, all that.
But it was also, for me
it was also a mission
to spread the love of beer.
I know it sounds a little--
but I actually mean it.
When I go to Mexico and
become a part of that scene,
and go to a festival that's
like the [? hit name ?]
for the festival,
it's to show them
or to teach them how you
can do it, and tell them
about how we do it in the USA,
and how we do it in Europe.
And that's the fun part.
JOSHUA DAVID STEIN: I
think one of the things
you talk a lot about
is that you can
make tremendous beer anywhere.
It's not like a brewery
that's not making great beer
can't make great beer.
It's in the recipe.
JEPPE JARNIT-BJERGSO:
Yeah, totally.
That's also one of the big
differences between wine-
and beer-making, and why
beer-making in many ways
is more approachable.
I mean, I get asked a lot,
how do you see yourself?
As a scientist or an
artist or a chemist?
And I always answer, I
see myself as a cook,
because what I do is the
same thing that Daniel does.
We take some
different ingredients,
we put them together in
a certain kind of way,
and we try to make
something that tastes good.
And that's all that
matters, you know?
Nothing else matters
when you make food.
when you make beer.
It has to taste good.
Otherwise, there's
no reason to do it.
And-- what was the question?
JOSHUA DAVID STEIN: That was it.
JEPPE JARNIT-BJERGSO:
That was the question.
JOSHUA DAVID STEIN: The
question's actually, like,
how far you push innovation.
How important is it
to innovate, for you?
JEPPE JARNIT-BJERGSO:
I push it a lot.
I'm known for pushing it
more than most people.
And it's, again, it's not that
I push it just to push it.
I do it because I get this idea.
It's more like I have this idea
of something I want to taste,
and nobody else
has done it before.
I have to do it to myself.
And that's definitely
something that
drives me a long way in my
view, maybe because I love food,
and I spend all my time
and all my money eating.
If it's from street
kitchens to the best
restaurants in the world, I just
love to put things in my mouth.
That can sound a bit weird.
But I really like flavors.
And that's not just beer, it's
food and beer and cocktails
and coffee and wine
and everything.
And it interests me so much
that I want to taste everything
there is in this world, and some
of that I have to do myself.
DANIEL BURNS: I
mean, innovation is--
having worked at these
Fat Duck and Noma,
you see 20 to 30 people
come in [INAUDIBLE] for free
every month.
And that's-- people
oftentimes going into, like,
write down all the
recipes they can,
and then go back to wherever
they work and just copy it,
you know?
So that's, like, totally
crazy in my mind,
that anyone would want to do
that, or choose to do that.
So for me the big thing is,
I've seen a lot of things
from these best chefs in the
world, and I'm conscious of it,
and I will never copy
anything I've learned.
The innovation is like,
OK, I've seen that and that
with a carrot, for example.
What am I going to do now?
JOSHUA DAVID STEIN:
So it's almost
like you made a challenge
for yourself, because you've
seen some of the best, most
innovative and best ideas
in the world, and you
have to now avoid those.
DANIEL BURNS: I mean, obviously,
and that's the thing I always
say to young cooks, too.
You can't just, like, I'm going
to work with my buddy who's
a chef for two years.
Well, you've got to
careful about that,
because it informs exactly
how you think about food.
Whether you're
conscious of it or not.
Because you go home and
cook, and then you're like,
I think I'm going to make
flank steak with potatoes.
That's what's on the menu
in my section right now.
You know?
It's hard to get out of it
once you choose a restaurant.
But innovation, I'm very
conscious of where I've been,
what I've learned,
and then how I
can adapt it to make it feel
like our own in the kitchen
we're trying to do.
But it's important.
The one big thing
everyone I think
comes to Luksus
thinking a little bit
is that new Nordic,
Rene's scope of influence
has been very wide, and--
JOSHUA DAVID STEIN:
He's the owner of Noma.
DANIEL BURNS: Yeah,
Rene Redzepi from Noma.
But I don't think new Nordic's
possible here in North America.
But the use of less
proteins and more vegetables
is something I've taken
very much to heart,
and so it's actually
possible to have
quite a long-format tasting
menu, but still feel nice
and a little bit
refreshed at the end.
JOSHUA DAVID STEIN: Have
a spring in your step.
DANIEL BURNS: So that's
the other thing, too.
You find so often when
these restaurants, they
have a tasting menu and
a la carte, and then
you just get super-full
when you take
the tasting menu sometimes.
So I'm conscious about how much
food you eat by the end also.
JOSHUA DAVID STEIN: We wanted
to open it up for questions.
These guys are obviously, have a
lot of expertise and knowledge,
and are, you know,
kind of friendly,
so they might answer
things if you ask them it.
AUDIENCE: So this is
a question for Jeppe.
Seems like you experiment
a lot and make a lot
of really interesting beers.
I'm sure you have
experiments that have failed,
and stuff that's
just come out awful.
So I'm kind of
curious if you could
talk a little bit about
something that you
were excited about and you
tried and it just didn't work.
JEPPE JARNIT-BJERGSO: Actually
I haven't had too many fails.
I've obviously been
asked that question,
have you ever done anything
that tasted terrible?
I had done a few beers that I
definitely wouldn't do again.
One of them was--
you can definitely
call that a fail, because
I made a beer in Denmark,
in the very beginning
of Evil Twin,
where I blended the beer with
[? 10% ?] wine, Chardonnay.
Because an old
brewery in Belgium
had done the same thing in
the '90s, and I loved it,
and I wanted to do it.
And the beer came
out really good.
I blended it, came
We wanted to export
it to the USA,
but it's illegal to sell a
beer and wine blend in the USA.
So I made an experiment
where I actually
used grape juice to see if I
can ferment it with the beer
and see how that came out.
Not the same thing.
So that was definitely a fail.
I had an idea it wouldn't
come out the same, obviously,
because it's not wine.
But, you know,
fermented grape juice
should be close to something
you could call wine.
But it did not taste as good.
JOSHUA DAVID STEIN: I
remember there was something
about blueberry skins.
JEPPE JARNIT-BJERGSO: That
was actually not a beer
done under Evil Twin.
I made a beer with
a brewery in Belgium
called Cantillon which
is known for-- we still
make it actually-- for
[INAUDIBLE] many beers.
And we used blueberries,
and they had never
used blueberries before.
And the first year
we made it, we just
added whole blueberries.
But it's something-- you know,
blueberries have the hard skin,
and if you don't break it down
before you add it to the beer,
I don't know exactly
what happened.
But something on the skin turned
the beer almost into vinegar,
and it tasted pretty
terrible actually.
The year after, we
froze the blueberries
before we added them, because
that breaks the berry down.
And now we freeze it,
and you know, it works.
But that was definitely
kind of a failure as well.
JOSHUA DAVID STEIN: They'll
also give beer recommendations
if you ask.
AUDIENCE: Is your beer, just--
is it bottled or canned beer?
JEPPE JARNIT-BJERGSO: What
do I think of it, of canned?
We're moving all our beers,
or pretty much all, in cans.
We've been doing that
last couple of years.
It's way better.
I mean, it's better for the
beer, it's better for storage,
it's better for the environment,
it's cheaper, it looks cooler.
I mean, it's-- I know, canned,
10 years ago if you sold beer
in a can, you wouldn't buy it,
because you considered it bad
beer, pretty much.
But that has definitely changed.
I actually read that more
than 50% of the craft beer
is in cans now, which
is kind of cool.
But it's just a better
media to put it in.
I mean, I'm glad someone
figured that out.
AUDIENCE: A bunch of us in
the room are home brewers.
Can you talk about
your home brewing setup
that you've had over the
years, or still have?
JEPPE JARNIT-BJERGSO: I
don't have it anymore.
I started homebrewing-- I think
I did my first batch of beer
in 2000, maybe?
2001?
I don't know.
You guys probably have
cool setups and everything.
We used plastic parts.
Everything was
kitchenware, pretty much.
You couldn't get fancy
systems back then.
I see homebrewing
systems now that
looks like real breweries,
which is kind of cool.
I mean, when I started
homebrewing I was just
like everybody else, you know?
I was drinking
beer, and I thought
it would be fun to
actually see if you could
make something that
tasted as good as the ones
that we bought.
And I found out pretty fast
that you actually could.
My advice to homebrewers
is always just
experiment, because some
of the best beers I've made
came from just trying
new things out,
and not really knowing
what I was doing.
But, you know, just see if it
worked, and often it actually
came out really good.
So, I mean, I had a
very primitive setup.
What is yours?
AUDIENCE: All grain, just like
10-gallon pot mashed down.
JEPPE JARNIT-BJERGSO:
So it's not
one of those fancy things that
looks like a real brewery.
AUDIENCE: I don't think I
know anyone in New York that
has a nice big system.
JEPPE JARNIT-BJERGSO: Maybe not.
JOSHUA DAVID STEIN: I'm
surprised there's no one here
in the Googleplex.
AUDIENCE: We've tried.
JOSHUA DAVID STEIN: How
far did you guys get?
AUDIENCE: Not very.
AUDIENCE: Yes, for Jeppe.
Just curious whether
the beers that you serve
are best paired with fine
dining, with any dining,
or on their own.
Does it make a difference
in terms of how
to best appreciate these beers?
JEPPE JARNIT
BJERGSO: Definitely.
If I understand
the question, what
is the beers that
we use at Luksus,
if they are best for that.
They're best for drinking.
They just happened to pair
well with Daniel's food.
I mean, when we
opened the restaurant,
we hadn't done it before.
We hadn't opened a
restaurant before.
We hadn't done a restaurant
with beer pairings.
Obviously we had an idea of
what we were going to do,
but with the evolution
of his restaurant
and how Daniel was
cooking, the beer pairings
have changed also.
And we have realized that
what we use the most now
is beers with some
kind of wild yeast.
If it's been [INAUDIBLE] so
[INAUDIBLE] or whatever it is,
and that's just because it
works well with Daniel's food,
because Daniel's food is very
without some organic flavors
like earthy and a
little bit funky.
And you know he's used
fermentation and pickling
and all that.
So we just figured out
that that works best.
Had we done an old-school
French restaurant,
we probably would
have done wine.
But had we done a French
restaurant with beer,
we would probably have
used different beers,
more dark and full-bodied.
AUDIENCE: I guess
I just sort of get
the idea of pairing both
from the food and the drink
point of view, whether the
beer makes the food better,
or the food makes
the beer better.
JOSHUA DAVID STEIN: It's
like a true marriage.
DANIEL BURNS: I think that a
good example is, maybe, there's
the sour beer taste
at first, and then
the dish is quite sweet.
They go somewhere together.
With wine, it's going to
happen less, in my experience.
The wine is going
to-- the character
of the wine is going to stand
much more separately to when
you taste it with
the dish, I think.
So I think beer is
good in that aspect,
and you can choose
beers that, like, really
harmonize with the dish.
JOSHUA DAVID STEIN: I think it's
also a matter of all the beers
that you have at Luksus.
They can stand on their
own, and they're wonderful.
It's not that you can pair
every beer with fine dining.
Some beers are just-- and we had
talked about, like, super-sour.
And it's, like, not every
beer-- I don't know, I mean,
in my experience-- is suitable,
really, for pairing this way.
Sometimes it's dominant
and so strongly-flavored
that you'd have a hard
time finding harmony.
JEPPE JARNIT-BJERGSO:
Yeah, I mean some beers,
like some wines, you
just want to drink alone.
Some beers you just
want to drink alone.
AUDIENCE: So essentially, I
believe there are two schools
of thought, which is
for example the Germans,
that if you put more than water
and barley and like the four
essential elements of the
beer, you cannot call it beer.
And then you have
the free-for-all,
like you can add corn and
you can add maybe yogurt even
to a beer, and then call it--
JEPPE JARNIT BJERGSO:
I've done that.
AUDIENCE: Like, you
may-- as you said before,
like you look for specific
tastes and flavors,
and you're in search
of specific things.
But what are your
thoughts on the people
that just, like, put
beer in whatever they
find in the garage, and then mix
it and then they call it a beer
and then put it out there?
JEPPE JARNIT-BJERGSO:
I mean, I think
that's a couple of
different questions.
Let's take the German
purity law first.
It's not a law anymore, so you
can-- even the Germans could
put olive in their beer now.
I mean, I actually
think it's kind of cool,
that-- I'm not a
big fan of laws,
but I think it's kind
of cool that they
had this way of developing
their beer scene in Germany,
where they had to stick
to the rules of only
the four main ingredients,
because, you know,
the best pilsners in the
world with no comparison
comes out of Germany,
for the reason
that they have done
over 500 years,
and have been able to do
whatever else they have.
But you know what I mean.
They've definitely
perfected what they've
perfected about what they did.
But it also limits them a lot,
in terms of what they can do,
in terms of doing whatever.
I can't say I'm not a
fan of it, because I
do a lot of experiments, but
you know as I also explained,
I always have the
end product in mind.
I always have in mind, you
know, I might add olive,
or I might ferment it in my
garage inside my car's fuel
tank, something like that.
But it has to taste
good, you know?
And that's very important
to me, because people
that read about me and
the beers that I make
might think this
guy's just [INAUDIBLE]
and off doing crazy
things, so that people
have something to talk about.
That's not what it's about.
I always aim to get balance.
I always aim to get
good flavors out of it.
And yeah, sometimes you would
say it's a little bizarre.
I did a beer in Norway
with pizza [INAUDIBLE].
That was pretty much
the only exception
where we just did it for fun.
But you know, in
general, I think
if you have that in mind
when you make a beer,
it should be free for all
to do whatever they want.
I mean, some people
now experiment,
we experiment with yeast, hops,
obviously, malts, adjuncts,
different ingredients,
but now people
have started to experiment
with fermenters,
concrete fermenters,
[INAUDIBLE] fermenters.
I actually think
that's pretty cool,
because we might
expose some new or find
some new flavors from that.
JOSHUA DAVID STEIN: In the back.
AUDIENCE: Hi, thanks
for being here.
Two questions.
So one is, can you
give us a sneak preview
of what might be coming
up on your next iteration
of your menu?
And then the other is, do you
have any good recommendations
for chili beer, like spicy beer?
DANIEL BURNS: I'll leave the
spicy beer to [? Liam. ?] Yeah,
so we've changed the
main course recently,
which is duck right now.
So that will stay for
the next few weeks.
And then we're doing--
there's always a broth course.
The snacks change most
often, so that can
be changed different every day.
But the broth we do every menu.
And right now it's
roasted turnip broth,
and it's changing to an onion
broth with asparagus and crab
next.
So that should happen
in the next few days.
And then the first serving is
like chef's-- or like longing
for the green things, and
this is more like a salad
at the start, with veal
tongue at the moment,
with warm vinaigrette.
And then rhubarb just
came out, so soon
as it's here I jump on a
rhubarb dessert pretty fastish,
I would say.
So the main dishes
evolve, sort of constantly
changing, where I'll change
the broth and the salad
will change next week, and then
be time to change the duck.
The duck, the main
course, is the one
to sort of manage
the most, because we
age the ducks 10 to 12 days.
And then you have to
find the right supplier
and figure out the
cooking method fully
before you put it on the menu.
So I would say overall, if
we change the menu 10 times
a year, the main course
might change only eight,
because of all that stuff--
because you don't want to just
say, oh, give me some ducks.
You want to source
everything properly,
and then set up the--
also from their side,
even a small restaurant,
the lamb for example
we get from Elysian Farm.
That's-- Thomas Keller
uses them, and you know,
I try to change my lamb
neck order from 10 to 12,
and she's like freaking
out on the email.
It's quite-- certain good
products, for especially
proteins, are
highly sought after,
so you have to be a little bit
careful how you manage that.
JOSHUA DAVID STEIN:
The other thing,
just to mention,
about the menu too,
also have this thing
called the second course.
DANIEL BURNS: So I'll never copy
anything I've done anywhere,
but that was a really
cool thing at Noma.
There was a la carte and
tasting when I started,
and so there was just
a choice of three.
How a lot of restaurants do
it-- three starters, three
main course, three dessert.
And those were
classic dishes that
had been on the tasting
menu and everyone loved it.
And so they put it to
the a la carte, which
is one of the coolest
ways I've ever
seen anyone run an a la carte.
It's basically classic
hits of the restaurant
for the a la carte menu.
So for the main dish,
though, you would get, say,
duck breast, and
then soon after,
when the main dish
was cleared out,
you'd get a second serving
of the leg or the neck
or something else.
JOSHUA DAVID STEIN:
It's like a related--
DANIEL BURNS: Yes,
so it's a way to show
conscious use of the
product, and also--
but back when I first started--
Jeppe can speak to you,
but Scandinavians didn't
used to eat out that much
at fine dining places.
And so oftentimes the
guests would be like,
no, no, we didn't order this.
No, you don't have to pay
extra, it's just part of the--
JEPPE JARNIT-BJERGSO: Danish
people's favorite food is free.
JOSHUA DAVID STEIN: Chili beer.
JEPPE JARNIT-BJERGSO: An
example of a good chili beer?
AUDIENCE: Yeah I've tried
the [INAUDIBLE], I think?
JEPPE JARNIT-BJERGSO:
That's not a chili beer.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JEPPE JARNIT BJERGSO: That's
a version of [INAUDIBLE].
Did you like it?
AUDIENCE: It's delicious.
I love chili beers.
JEPPE JARNIT-BJERGSO: I've
made a couple of chili beers.
The most common one is a
stout like [INAUDIBLE].
It's made in Spain.
I don't speak Spanish, but I
want to give it a Spanish name
just to have a connection.
When you make a
spicy beer, when you
want some spiciness in
there, or some hotness,
the most common one
is definitely a stout.
It just works.
You know, like chocolate
and chili works really well.
So a stout has a lot
of chocolate flavors
to it, so it works really well.
I also made last
year a bit of beer
called Spicy Nachos,
that we later
changed to Firewater, which is
actually the total opposite.
So that's a pale ale, 5.5%,
very light and refreshing.
And I used the jalapenos,
instead of red chilis.
We used them fresh.
So it has a lot of
jalapeno flavor,
but not [INAUDIBLE] on the
spiciness, but more the chili
flavor.
And it actually
worked extremely well.
I mean, that was one
of my experiments
where we're like, oh shit, this
actually works really well.
DANIEL BURNS: Very juicy.
JEPPE JARNIT-BJERGSO:
Yeah, it was
just like you have
a lot of the aroma,
you have a lot of fresh
jalapeno which smells awesome,
but you didn't get that crazy
bite, you got a little bite.
DANIEL BURNS: That
one's in the book,
and then I decided to
pair spicy nachos with it.
JOSHUA DAVID STEIN:
They're delicious.
The best nacho recipe.
JEPPE JARNIT-BJERGSO: We have a
new beer coming out in the fall
that we just went to Lima,
Peru, to make a test batch.
So it's a porter made
with purple potato,
some Peruvian corn, and Peruvian
chili-- I forgot the name,
but it's not very spicy,
but it's extremely aromatic.
It almost tastes like a
tomato, but a spicy tomato.
So that one is coming
out in the fall.
I'm excited about that.
JOSHUA DAVID STEIN:
Do you have a--
AUDIENCE: Yeah, actually.
So curious, when you
go to other breweries
and you're using
their facilities,
how much are you working
with the folks there?
What's the interaction like?
And then, I guess, how does
that compare to working
in other folks' restaurants?
JEPPE JARNIT-BJERGSO: I mean,
I always make the recipes.
And sometimes they
give me feedback,
and sometimes I have
to change things,
because [INAUDIBLE] with beer
I make a recipe and that's it.
But 10% oats, I use a
lot of oats, both in IPAs
and stouts for the
mouth feel and all that.
Some breweries are just not
set up to use a lot of oats.
They might come back and say,
you know, if we use 10% oats,
we got to get a stock
mass, and it's going
to take us 24 hours to make it.
And we got a [INAUDIBLE] and
then you have to adjust it.
And I think it's
kind of a fun thing
to do what I do, brew at all
these different breweries,
because it always turns you to
rethink what you do, you know?
It's not like they
come back to you,
you have to redo the whole
recipe. [INAUDIBLE] I might
make another beer, but
actually I have to adjust.
Plus sometimes we go
to a certain country
and I have an idea of
something I want to do,
but I can't get the
ingredients, you know?
Specifically hops in Asia.
I brewed in Taiwan and Japan
and couple of other countries,
and you know, it's hard to
get some hops over there.
And I might have this idea of
making this IPA [INAUDIBLE]
that works really
well with this hop,
but if I can't get the
hop, I can't do it.
So--
DANIEL BURNS: So a lot
of conversations happen.
In terms of working in other
people's kitchens or-- the most
important, we've started to
invite guest chefs to cook with
us at Luksus, which is-- I
mean, it's-- you invite friends,
and it can be amazing.
The thing about collaboration
is something good
is going to come out.
You have no idea what
before you start.
That's the thing
I love about it.
Maybe you're going to learn
about a new product that they
bring, or some guy's
knives he brought.
It can be anything that's
going to-- the coolest part is
for the cooks to
bring-- [INAUDIBLE] just
came from California.
He's going to open up a
place called Single Thread.
And, you know, he's
pretty known chef,
so to expose just for the
cooks that you work with,
trying to mentor, to
have them just plop
someone else in the kitchen
and see how they work, and then
further go into other
restaurants around the world
to either cook with friends or
people you've never met before,
is really great.
You send the recipes ahead
and then they're like,
well, we don't have--
we're in Australia,
we don't have that right now.
So then figure it out.
Once you get there, that's the
coolest part, too, you know?
We're all focused
on-- restaurants
are places for
experiences for people,
so you just try to maximize
that with-- and figure it out
together.
That's the coolest
part about cooking,
because if you're going
to another restaurant,
that's all they're
concerned with, too.
It's how happy the guests
will be by the end.
JEPPE JARNIT-BJERGSO: In
terms of what I just said,
one thing is when I go out
and use someone else's brewery
to make a beer, another
thing is obviously
I don't just make my own recipe.
I make collaborations.
I collaborate on the
recipe, you know?
I know there's a lot of beer
collaborators out there.
I actually think there's too
much these days, everybody
collaborating with everybody.
I think it's
important when you do
that, you have to bring in both
breweries' ideas into the beer,
because sometimes you
collaborate and it doesn't
fit either brewery.
And I'm like, what
the hell is this?
That would be like Daniel
and some [INAUDIBLE]
a French restaurant, you know?
It would just be too weird.
So when we do
collaborate, we definitely
bring in each other's ideas.
And I have, oh, I like to
use this, I like to use that.
I'm doing a pretty
cool collaboration--
I did the first one, we're
doing the second one next week--
with a brewery called
Trillium in Boston,
which is like the talk
of the town right now.
And I love those guys,
became good friends
of mine, where we wanted
to do two different beers,
an IPA that they're
famous for and a stout
that I'm kind of famous for.
So I gave them an
IPA recipe and they
made a Trillium version of it.
And they gave me a stout recipe
and I made an Evil Twin version
of it.
That's kind of a cool
way to collaborate,
when we take something from
each other and rethink it.
Actually, if you've
been to our restaurant,
if you haven't,
what is it, June 23?
DANIEL BURNS: June 26.
JEPPE JARNIT-BJERGSO: June 26
is a good day, because we're
bringing Trillium in to us.
We're doing a big tasting.
We're also doing a
special dinner at Luksus,
where we only do Trillium
pairings with the food.
Have you heard about Trillium?
AUDIENCE: I think so.
JEPPE JARNIT-BJERGSO:
I mean, it's
like probably the most
talked-about brewery
in the country right now.
It's insane.
That's going to be a fun
day, so come to [INAUDIBLE].
DANIEL BURNS: We're going to
sell out just by word of mouth.
JEPPE JARNIT-BJERGSO: They're
rethinking the IPA, which
is crazy because the IPA
is like 400 years old,
and people have
rethought it many times.
Them and Tree House,
also in Massachusetts,
have created this
new style of IPAs
that is totally different
than just delicious.
It's pretty cool.
JOSHUA DAVID STEIN:
One more question.
AUDIENCE: I'm very honored that
you named some of the beers
after my name, Jesus.
JEPPE JARNIT-BJERGSO:
You can pay me later.
JOSHUA DAVID STEIN: Evil.
AUDIENCE: Also baby Jesus.
So what made you
make that choice,
and what do you
think about the fact
that some states have banned
the sales of your beer?
JEPPE JARNIT-BJERGSO:
Oh, that's only cool.
I'm not a religious guy.
Let me state that at first.
I'm from Denmark.
We are probably the most atheist
country in the world, I think.
It's a long story.
It was kind of a coincidence.
It was actually kind of a
lost in translation thing.
We were talking about
something, and at one point
I said, "Even more Jesus."
I said "Jesus" because something
was crazy, you say, "Jesus."
And then something
was even more crazy
and I said, "Even more Jesus."
And this guy I had
this conversation with
was like, this is the
perfect name for a beer.
I like the name, too.
It's very catchy and--
DANIEL BURNS: Stirs the pot.
JOSHUA DAVID STEIN: It
does you good to be banned.
JEPPE JARNIT BJERGSO: So now
we have bunch of Jesuses.
You have a lot of
beers out there.
Do you really?
That's awesome.
JOSHUA DAVID STEIN:
Well, guys, thank
you so much for
listening to us, and we
hope to see you in Greenpoint at
Torst and Luksus at some point.
[APPLAUSE]